we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a really good
question about the Fox News text message
Scandal listen to this
hey David I just wanted
to tell us briefly about the Fox News
Scandal
um I know that you've been covering it
really well
I just have a comment you know I think
that all of this stuff that's coming out
in general simply won't have as big of
an impact because the people that watch
Fox News will never see it in other
words the reason they haven't settled
which most people are like why haven't
they settled this is very damaging to
them because if they settle they have to
say to their audience listen we lied to
you and they probably have to say it a
hundred times a day but the point is
that they make more money doing it and
they know this therefore why would they
settle they'll lose 1.6 billion it'll
hurt them so here's the thing the caller
is correct that a lot of you know we
asked yesterday and the day before
are Tucker's viewers going to abandon
Tucker because they're Maga people and
they watch Tucker with the idea that
Trump's going to be praised by Tucker
and now Tucker is exposed in text
messages saying he hates Trump
passionately
Tucker's viewers just won't even hear
about that story because Fox News isn't
covering the story and they only watch
Fox News but there's another aspect to
this even if the caller is right that if
Fox were to settle they might have to do
a Maya culpa and say we were wrong we
lied about this and that I don't even
think their followers would care about
that I genuinely don't I think they'd go
the liberal media forced him to do it
the liberal establishment forced them to
do it they didn't really lie they told
the truth so I actually think the caller
is wrong in that particular sense let me
know what you think we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com don't miss it